[Musik]
bismark erst ist platin blm unique habe
für das semester dachte ich ich würde
helle ries letzte woche schon abhaken
aber ich habe so viel zu sagen weil sie
jetzt kommen halloween hält beide in
einer sitzung
und das ist auch irgendwie nichts
verkehrt okay er hat schon eins gleich
das ist nicht verkehrt weil sie beide
aus dem sollten jahr unter zwang und
vielleicht andere ähnlichkeiten haben
vor allem wie ich am ende wie viel zeit
habe sagen werde
wenn wir die frage ernst nehmen sind
sind diese figuren figuren philosophen
wirklich philosophinnen sich
herausstellen dass eine positive antwort
wahrscheinlich hauptsächlich dadurch
bekräftigt werden könnte dass sie beide
interessante theorie theorien zur ethik
haben und das ist nicht unbedingt der
fall also man vielleicht würde man
meinen ja okay das klingt irgendwie
weidlich aber wir werden in den
kommenden wochen sein dass handel metall
philosophinnen eigentlich viel mehr apps
technologie und vielleicht mathe physik
besprochen
vor allem bei diesen zwei big video
wirklich im vordergrund würde ich sagen
okay
bevor wir halloween im härtegrad
besprechen nur kurz wollte ich erwähnen
dass das nicht die erste frauen im
christlichen mittelalter oder latin jazz
und im mittelalter die schriften
hergestellt haben die irgendwas mit
philosophie zu tun haben könnten
ich denke hier an zwei frauen
droht das aus schon aus der
karolingischen zeit des 19 jahrhunderts
sie lädt dem in der ersten hälfte des
neunten jahrhunderts und dann auch
tollen toller name roswitha und sie
lebte im zehnten jahrhundert
ich erwähne sie erstens weil ich im
insel in der ersten sitzung gesagt habe
das hier ist ein bisschen darum leute zu
erwähnen die immer vergessen werden
aber auch weil sie irgendwie eine
vorahnung geben was wir dann in der
späteren zeit haben werden vor allem
nicht weil sie so philosophisch
interessant sind als schriftstellerinnen
aber weil sondern weil sie von gestalt
ihrer texte an
zum beispiel hält das fängt schon bei
bruder andy hill das ist ja nur ein
verhaltener werk und das ist irgendwie
biografisch betont wobei nicht so nicht
so biografisch betont die von bei
illegal
sie war eigentlich eine reiche frau
hatte irgendwelche verhältnis zum könig
oder kaiserlichen hof nämlich ihr mann
werner kieser glaube ich war im hochbau
mitglied des hofes von ludwig der fromme
also nachfolger von karl der große und
sie erkennen sie deswegen weil sie einen
berg geschrieben hat was noch erhalten
ist natürlich auf dateien und das ist
ein buch oder buch leihen business netz
für ihren sohn der anderswo war und weil
sie ihn so vermisst hat hat sie dieses
werk für ihn verfasst wo sie
rath anbietet eigentlich ethische rats
also ist sie es nennt er sogar ein
liberales also ein kleines buch der über
moral und das würde
wir wissen sogar dass das 1 843 verfasst
wurde und hier betont sie zum beispiel
dass ihr sohn jungfrau bleiben soll dass
er heiratet kann eine so einen jungen
frau bleiben jungs ein junger mann auf
jeden fall nichts sie wissen schon dass
er heiratet und was auch nicht typisch
ist und was wir auch bei helfe kann zum
beispiel sein werden ist dass sie ihre
eigene schwäche als frau betont zum
beispiel gibt es eine sehr schöne stelle
wo es ist und das ich glaube dass die
mutter von ihnen werden das erkennen
wahrscheinlich diese strategie sich seit
schwach als ich bin in verstand und
würdig und erledigen
trotzdem bin ich deine mutter und dann
sagt sie mögen irgendwie er dann
vorgehen soll
es ist interessant also da haben wir
wirklich ein einfach einen fall wo wir
sehen das mit der frauen oft innerhalb
einer familie zu sagen intellektuell
tätig sein können was auch hier
interessant ist
bei bruder ist dass ihr text eine
mischung aus prosa und poesie ist und an
sie kennt mehrere klassische texte die
der brief zeigt und diese mischung aus
diesen zwei journals der schrift
erinnert sehr stark an britney spears
hat trost der philosophie geschrieben
und da inszeniert er oder beschreibt er
wie im gefängnis sitzt wartet auf seine
hinrichtung dann kommt seine philosophie
zu ihm und entfaltet all die gründe
warum er nicht verzweifeln soll und das
ist auch so aufgestellt dass er
abwechselnd immer gedichte schreibt und
dann großer teile die das entweder
erklären oder irgendwie thematisch mit
der poesie zu tun haben
im nackten nächsten jahrhunderts im
zehnten jahrhundert haben wir roswitha
und sie war eine nonne benediktinischen
ohne nonne in gandersheim abteil das ist
in sachsen also wenn es irgendwelche
sächsische leute hergibt
nein keine niemand aus sachsen okay ich
wollte sagen das ist der moment wo sie
sich was sie stolz sein können
und sie hat mehrere werke geschrieben
erstens hat sie auch poesie also frei
stehende poetische werke geschrieben
es gibt eine stelle wo es sie sich mehr
oder weniger beklagt dass es schwierig
ist für eine frau poesie zu schreiben
erklärt nicht warum
vielleicht weil sie nicht so gut
ausgebildet wurde wie männliche
schriftsteller
diese gerichte sind sehr religiös
thematische religiös und beschreiben vor
allem also jedes gedicht ist einen
bestimmten heiligen gewidmet
einschließlich jungfrau maria dann hat
sie auch theaterstücke geschrieben und
diese theaterstücke nehmen aus modell
den antiken dichters sie es ich würde
sagen eigentlich weniger philosophisch
interessant ist oder weil du das
wirklich das geht wirklich über ethik
und das ist eigentlich ein typisches
beispiel so populär ethik könnten wir
sagen wenn sie zurückdenken an was wir
in der antike gesehen haben sie erinnern
sich vielleicht daran dass wir diese
briefe von pädagoginnen hatten die auch
ethische beratung an familienmitglieder
oder freundinnen geboten haben und daran
kurz vita ist mehr wie eine vorahnung
von dem was wir in hildegard finden
werden woran war illegal auch
theaterstücke geschrieben hat diese
theaterstücke darstellen
die geschichten mehreren heiligen aus
der antike da und mein beschreiben
manchmal sogar mattiert und also ich da
steht im stück das einmal schwerer sich
beklagen soll wir im öl
verbrennt sowie das wie sie das
inszenieren wollte weiß ich nichts habe
also wenn sie ihr wissen über terence
wissen dass das wahrscheinlich mehr als
ich weiß aber er war hat der tierische
werke geschrieben oft ziemlich mit sind
also mit sexuellen themen und so
und sie wollte dass irgendein scheinen
irgendwie sozusagen reinigen und das als
muster nehmen aber christlich dann durch
hören aber interessant ist dass sie
diese antike tradition kennt und
übernimmt um ihre eigene werke zu
schreiben
wie gesagt kann man das nichts also die
gerichten und theaterstücke kann man
nicht alles für diese werke beschreiben
so weit wie ich sein kann
allerdings gibt es eine passage wo sie
auch die dame philosophie erwähnt und
sagt sie übernimmt ihre kunst von der
dame philosophie hier ist vielleicht
nichts schlechtes daran zu erinnern dass
philosophie in dieser zeit eine viel
breitere bedeutung hat als für uns dass
es in vielleicht bekannt dass
philosophie konnte konnte auch zum
beispiel natur verlasse die bedeutung
zum beispiel physik oder kosmologie aber
für das solche ausbildung damals hieß
auch c viren als die sprachkunst und
also logik grammatik und reiter und eine
rhetorische ausbildung würde zum
beispiel jemand wie mitteilen
terence bekannt machen also wenn es wenn
sie über dame für das entspricht könnte
es sein dass sie da darunter literatur
versteht was wir für das vieh nicht
unbedingt verstehen
das sind zwei frühere frauen wovon wir
mindestens werke haben
soweit ich weiß ist oder die erste
mutige frau von dem wir haben also die
erhalten ist okay aber die interessanter
für uns ist halloween
und das ist wahrscheinlich schon ein
bekannter name
sie war natürlich die liebhaberin von
petsos abbados ein führender philosoph
im zwölften jahrhundert und wir kennen
die liebesgeschichte und zur goethe
könnte man sogar sagen
von alois und beladung aus zwei
hauptquellen und das sind erstens ein
werk von aber leider selbst namens
historia calamita
sie sehen schon an den titel dass das
nicht gut ausgehen wird und dann ein
briefwechsel also mehrere briefe
zwischen alois und avocados es ist sehr
wertvoll weil wir hier texte haben wo es
in ihr so sangen ihrer eigenen stimme
schreibt
natürlich war wie so oft würde schon ab
und zu bezweifelt ob die briefe
authentischen zum beispiel könnte man
vielleicht meinen dass die briefe erst
ein jahrhundert oder zwei jahren
jahrhundert später verfasst wurden ja
sehr entscheidend hier ist anderen autor
von der romandie holz der diese briefe
sehr die haben ihm sehr gefallen und er
hat die briefe dann in die französische
sprache oder mittelalterliche
französisch übersetzt also bis dahin
besteht vielleicht die möglichkeit dass
er oder sonst werden die briefe erfunden
hat aber die ich würde sagen die stimme
von abos ist so ist zu erkennen
in seinen briefen und die briefe von
hier sind auch sehr überzeugend und aber
leider sagt auch in history calamita das
alles schon vor der beziehung ihm
bekannt war also nur das dass sie einen
ruf hatte dass sie so klug und zu sagen
ja eigenwillig war und das war für ihn
ein grund warum er sie kennenlernen
wollte als sehr sehr praktisch gehört
wie intelligent diese frau sei und
wollte unbedingt sehen wir den kennen
lernen und also ich bin relativ
überzeugt dass die briefe die halloween
oder zugeschrieben werden
wirklich von hier sind sie kennen
vielleicht die geschichte was in den
zwei passiert ist aber kurzum führen sie
eine lebenslang so an dass sie ihre
schulen wird und er bildet sie den
vielleicht religion und vor allem in
diesen philosophischen kunsten haus also
vor allem grammatik logik usw
also das heißt sie hatte den besten
philosoph des jahrhunderts als lehrer
und dann und es wird zum teil sehr
detailliert was wir davon erfahren zum
beispiel dass sie ihn oder er sie oder
beides verführt hat in einer kirche
das wird erwähnt weil er sagt nicht
schlimm es war das zu machen und im
allgemeinen beschreibt er die affäre als
ein ereignis worüber er ist das gewissen
hat oder mehr als schlechtes gewissen
also für seine einstellung ist mehr oder
weniger dass das was ihnen passiert ist
wirklich eine gerechte strafe war für
das was sie miteinander gemacht haben
weil sie nicht verheiratet waren und so
weiter dann würde das entdeckt und vor
allem von alois ockl und war gar nichts
froh darüber und wollte dass die zwei
heiraten
in den briefen haben oder den
angeblichen briefen aber gehen wir davon
aus dass sie echt sind in einen
schuldigen in history akademie taten
also es definitiv erst fast alle ladens
zusammen erlöses gründe dagegen dass sie
heiraten also anscheinend wollte er sie
heiraten uns ja gesagt nein nein nein
schlagt die idee dass wir sowieso nicht
das wird sowieso nichts bringen also
mein onkel ist sowieso wütend und auch
wenn wir wenn wir heimlich heiraten wer
noch wütender
wenn dann sie sagt aber auch wenn wir
heiraten dann haben wir eine familie und
das würde dich von philosophie
zurückhaltend es ist auch interessant
und sie zitiert dann eine reihe von
klassischen werken die gegen die er sich
äußern
also dass noch ein zeichen also noch
eine sehr gut gebildete frau und noch
ein seiten das so sagen die frau die in
historia kalamitäten vorkommt diabolos
beschreibt sie klingt wie die frau die
in den briefen auch auftaucht werden
weil sie haben nicht heimlich geheiratet
und der onkel hat das eigentlich aus
einem missverständnis weil er dachte
dass aber leider sie einführen wollte
hat er seine männer sie ihm in der nacht
geschickt wenn sie haben ihn genommen
und seien und wie sie diese kastriert
das ist richtig gewollt also sozusagen
wir wie es war
sie haben ihn kassiert und dann nach
dieser motivation sind beide dann in das
klosterleben gegangen
also er würde man sie würden ohne und er
hat sogar ein kloster aufgebaut was
ziemlich erfolgreich geworden ist sie
auch als aber das ist nicht wahr dass
sozusagen wie gesagt die gerechte strafe
für diese affäre und auch eigentlich ein
zusammenhang wo er seine lehre dann
weiter entfalten konnte konnte studenten
haben und es ist für ihn so sagen
irgendwie erfolgreich ausgegangen
das ist natürlich nichts genau wie er
das sich vorgestellt hat im voraus aber
er ist also man könnte fast sagen er ist
zufrieden mit diesem ergebnis oder gibt
dort tut so als ob er zu damit zufrieden
ist in der story kalamitäten was
deswegen sehr interessant ist ist das in
den briefen harrys überhaupt nicht
zufrieden ist wenn sie schreit hier
angeblich so schon als alte frau und
beschreibt wie sie immer noch mal lust
hat also für männer und dass das dass
sie das nicht befriedigen kann
sie ist eine sehr berühmte stelle die
ich einfach zitieren müsste sie erklärt
wie schlimm es für sie ist ohne ihn zu
leben und sagt selbst wenn kaiser
augustus mich heiraten würde und mir die
ganze welt gäbe hätte ich es lieber
nicht seine kaiserin zu sein sondern
eine höhere stelle also und da das seit
sie nachdem sie schon im kloster ist es
ist wirklich und übrigens das ist ein
grund warum manche leute die
authentizität zweifeln dass sie denke
denken wie können sie eine frauen
sollten jahrhundert das schreiben meine
antwort werde warum nicht und zweitens
mindestens müsste also die briefe haben
schon im 13 jahre existiert ja im 13
jahrhundert existiert denn sondern sich
in dem derzeit über satz hat also es war
bis dann plausibel dass eine frau das
schreiben könnte warum ist das nicht
dann versiegelt dass eine frau das
wirklich geschrieben hatte im solchen
jahrhunderts auf jeden fall was auch bei
halloween interessantes also die die
interessante stellen sind die stellen wo
sie eben diese argumente gegen die ehe
dann anbietet und dann in den briefen
die ist ein wo sie ihre einschätzung
hier des jetzigen lebens beschreibt in
ihre einschätzung ist dass ihr leben als
nonne wird
ich nichts bedeutet weil obwohl sie
äußerlich gut und tugendhaft lebt
innerlich hat sie diese tugend nichts
also sozusagen innerlich nichts frau
innerlich nicht keusch weil sie immer
noch habe lades haben will obwohl sie
natürlich äußerlich genau wie eine brave
lebt und das hat dann die interesse an
der philosophie zu sich genommen
denn es erinnert an eine ethische
theorie die wir bei aber la douce finden
also jetzt wollte ich dann was über
diese ethische theorie und dann kurz was
sagen darüber ob es wirklich plausibel
ist babbel das ist ethik mit der
einstellung harrys zu in verbindung zu
bringen
okay das und diese ethische theorie
kommt aus einem werk das heißt manchmal
einfach die ethik von abel hat manchmal
nennt man das kenne dich selbst das war
sein titel dafür und ich weiß dass die
diese vorlesung ist dazu gebiet mit sie
so überzeugen wie toll philosophinnen in
der antike mittelalter sind aber kurze
pause davon
dieser werk von abos ist auch toll
obwohl er von einem mann geschrieben
wird würde und das kann ich nur
empfehlen
das ist erstaunlich ich sage den podcast
ich berichte über ein gespräch was ich
hörte zwischen zwei experten der mit
deutlichen plus ev und der eine hat
irgendwas gesagt wie ja dass das ding
mit mit als offen ist das ist sie sagen
nie so und so und so also es gibt ich
weiß nicht was das war aber es gibt
irgendeine idee oder ausdruck oder sowas
das was nie bei mit der philosophie
auftaucht und der andere erwiderte doch
das kommt bei abo landes vor
und der erste sagte das zählt nichts
aber das war kein mittelalterliche
philosophie
er ist ein moderner philosoph die durch
die zeit zurück gegangen ist und legte
dann im sollten jahrhundert und wenn man
diese dieses werk liest versteht man
warum dass man das sagen würde es ist
wirklich sehr sehr interessant und sogar
fast als ob von einer analytischen
philosophie geschrieben also viele
beispiele
ein paar davon werde ich jetzt ja wieder
erzählen
ok die kennt ist ein langes
kompliziertes werk aber die kern theorie
dieses werkes hat mit dem lateinischen
wort intention zu tun
das würde ich als absicht übersetzen
die gründe liegen die idee hier ist wenn
jemand was machen will oder unternehmen
will hat er eine absicht das zu tun
im besten fall will er was gutes machen
zum beispiel er will geld für die
spenden
also er hat die absicht das zu tun
und dann führt er hoffentlich
erfolgreich diese absicht aus dadurch
dass er geld spendet und aber leider
will behaupten dass ethische
verantwortung also das was wir logen und
beschuldigen ist nichts tat was wirklich
ausgeführt wird sondern die absicht die
hinter der tat steckt das erinnert ein
bisschen an historische etic übrigens
und es kann sogar sein dass er irgendwie
immer irgendwelche werde von sadismus
beeinflusst würde aber ich würde sagen
dass er verteidigt und entwickelt diese
theorie viel besser als das was wir in
den store können selbst finden
obwohl die historiker auch toll sein tun
wie soll er das begründen also erstens
kann er uns darauf aufmerksam machen
dass man manchmal eine absicht hat und
tut sein bestes um irgendwas zu machen
also irgendwie so handeln und die
handlung scheitert obwohl man daran
nicht schuld ist zum beispiel ich will
geld spenden
also ich mach eine banküberweisung aber
irgendwas ist im system und das geld
kommt nicht an
und die frage wer dann ob ich so sagen
moralisch genau so coachte als ob als
ich würde wenn das geld ankommen würde
und hier ist placebo zu sagen ja also ob
das geld kommt an oder nicht ist
eigentlich egal
also so sagen ob ich die handlung
richtig ausführen kann oder nicht dass
es wirklich eine nebensache
die hauptsache ist dass ich die richtige
absicht hatte umgekehrt nehmen wir an
ich will was böses machen
also ich will zum beispiel jemanden aus
einem fenster werfen
das böse
und passt das zu gruselig es hätte
schlimmer sagen nein nein ich will aber
laders kassieren so also ich denke meine
männer um alle lade zu kassieren
aber die männer gehen in die falsche
wohnung und und niemandes zu hause gott
sei dank
und da passiert nichts aber das würde
dann sagen ich bin genauso schuldig als
wenn meine männer denkt man kassiert
hätten
wohlbemerkt natürlich vor gericht
also von also juristisch gesehen macht
es einen unterschied ob meine untertanen
habe laden finden oder nichts
weil wenn sie ihn finden kann ich vor
gericht genommen werden werden
wahrscheinlich wenn wenn nichts passiert
gebe es kein also es gibt nichts zu
bestrafen könnte man sagen und auch in
mindestens in amerika und nehme auch
hier auch nicht nehmen auch hier
wir unterscheiden zwischen mörder eine
tempo also mit uns weiß nicht wie es
weiter heißt beabsichtigt morgen
das wollte ich sogar extra drin und
interessant ist ist zu beobachten dass
man weniger strafe für absicht im ort
als vermag bekommt das ist vielleicht
irgendwie nachvollziehen aber ich würde
sagen dass eigentlich falsch also
mindestens in der moralischen sphäre
wenn du glück hast sozusagen und der
mann den sie umbringen will den
totschlag den beabsichtigten totschlag
überlebt bis du genauso schuldig das
sind nord glücksfall
er gibt auch beispiele wo es zum
beispiel 22 verschiedene menschen die
gleiche handlung dürfen aber als in
einem fall aus einer guten grund als
einen guten grund in einem anderen fall
als eine schlacken grund so ein beispiel
wir haben zwei richter jemand wird
und die müssen entscheiden ob der
gefangenen schuldig ist oder nicht
und der ein gericht überlegt welche
beweise es gibt und entscheidet sich ob
er schuldig und der welt hingerichtet
man habe leider sagt das ist gut das ist
gerecht der andere
der andere täter hat was gegen den
gefangenen sowie so ist sein feind und
um rache ausüben erklärt ihn für
schuldig und er wird auch hingerichtet
und er ist wirklich schuldig also der
erde oder sowas
die das ergebnis ist gerecht aber die
handlung des richters ist ungerecht oder
aber das würde sagen die handlung ist
gerecht aber sie die absicht dahinter
war nicht gerecht weil er hat das
richtige getan aber aus zu sagen hast
dem falschen grund oder her würde sagen
mit dem schlachten mit einem starken
intention also aus der falschen absicht
ist es auch interessant ist ist er
wieder so weit dass er nennt den fall
der soldaten die christus hingerichtet
haben
etwas gewagt dieses beispiel und dann
sagt er natürlich war das falsch aber
noch fächer ist wenn sie überzeugt
werden das ist richtig über werde ihn
hin zu richten und sie das nicht getan
hätten
weil dann hätten sie gegen ihre eigenen
absicht gehandelt und das ist schlecht
also die die der der idealfall ist dass
man aus einer guten absicht vorgeht und
dass die handlung erfolgreich
durchgezogen wird
und wenn du eine gute absicht hass und
man sie nicht folgst oder wenn du eine
schlechte absicht hass und sie folgt
dann bist du schuld ich übrigens an
er beschreibt auf mehreren fällen wo man
ja es ist eigentlich so mit den soldaten
und christus es gibt fälle wo man meint
dass man eine gute absicht hat also weil
natürlich für diese soldaten ist jesus
christus jemand der behauptet gott zu
sein und die glauben nicht dass er gott
sei und wenn er wirklich nicht gott ist
und behauptet dass er gott sei dank dass
er hingerichtet wird
laut abi lagers das problem ist nur er
ist wirklich gott also die gehen hier
falsch aber irgendwie sollen sie ihn
hinrichten weil sie sozusagen falsche
informationen haben also vielleicht
könnte man kurz um könnte man sagen man
es nur sozusagen moralisch im plan und
moralisch lobenswert wenn man die
richtige absicht hat also die absicht
hat irgendwas zu tun aus mit guten
informationen also müssen was machen
wollen was wirklich gutes machen wollen
und dann versuchst du dir das zu machen
also du wirst die absicht durch und ob
das hinhaut oder nicht das ist egal
okay das ist eine theorie sich theorie
täters nennen und ist ja auch sehr
plausibel würde ich sagen okay jetzt
zurück zu unsere unserer eigenen
interesse nämlich alois erinnerung was
sagt sie in den briefen sie sagt jetzt
obwohl ich als nonne und fromm und
keusch leben bin ich mit wirklich gut
weil innerlich bin ich nicht keusch und
sie sagt übrigens auch das die sünden
die sie und pilatus damals begangen
haben als sie diese labels liebesaffäre
hatten die waren keine sünden weil sie
aus lübeck gemacht würden und sie können
jetzt vielleicht schon im voraus sehen
was mehrere historiker behauptet haben
nämlich an dass das klingt alles wie
aber das ist absicht theorie also die
idee wäre unsere absicht damals war
nicht falsch weil war die absicht war
vielleicht meine liebe füreinander zu
zeigen und meine absicht jetzt ist
falsch also das was ich jetzt mache ist
nicht gut weil meine handlung passen
meine absicht nichts und unsere handlung
damals war mit war war auch war nicht
falsch weil die absicht dahinter gut war
das ist eine auslegung von alois briefe
die wir manchmal finden allerdings
ja ist auch ziemlich radikal oder
übrigens ich ich biete erlaubnis für gar
nichts hier heute ich beschreibe nur was
alois sagte fall sind damit wir uns
verstehen das ist nur geschichte der
philosophie
angewandte philosophie angewandte
philosophie der liebes erfahren dass wir
das ist ein kurs wo viele studenten
auftauchen
aber dass das führt ein bisschen in die
richtung die ich sowieso jetzt gehen
wollte weil ich bin nicht ganz überzeugt
dass das was alois wirklich dem was aber
leider sagen will entspricht und zwar
aus folgendem grund was sie sagt ist
eigentlich noch radikaler als das was
aber leider sagt also nur noch mal sagen
aber das sagt du musst eine gute
handlung machen wollen
aus einer guten absicht also wenn du
eine schlechte absicht hat eine gute
handlung zu machen
das zählt nicht als gut und das heißt du
musst du sagen die handlung die gute
handlung richtig identifizieren und
diese handlung dann beabsichtigen aus
der dieser absicht also du musst
sozusagen das gute zwecks dem guten
machen zum beispiel wenn du jemanden
richtig hinrich ist aber als an als
rache das sind nichts aber man sieht
hier das abi laer das offensichtlich
eine idee hat das handlung an sich
schlecht oder gut ist also es gibt
sozusagen zwei bedingungen gut zu sein
die handlung ist gut sein und die
absicht dahinter muss das gut hauptpunkt
seien vor allem mit dem fall der fälle
sagt was viel was eigentlich viel mehr
radikal ist nämlich sie will behaupten
dass eine angebliche sünder keine sünde
ist so lang die sünde aus einer guten
absicht oder aus einem guten grund
vielleicht durchgeführt wird
übrigens ich finde es auch ein bisschen
problematisch dass also wenn man es mit
pilates vergleicht das auch ein bisschen
problematisch das aber war das wirklich
von absicht spricht sie spricht von
motivation das was andere
die motivation ist keine absicht sie
kann auch eine absicht haben geht gegen
meine motivation so agieren zb ich will
unbedingt mehr essen habe ich habe die
absicht abzunehmen deswegen esse ich
nichts also was sie sagt hat mit
motivation zu tun nicht mit absicht
hessens dass ein zweites und hier wird
es deswegen zu radikal
sie sagt so lang meine motivation gut
ist alles was ich mache ist auch gut
das ist mindestens anscheinend das was
sie dann behaupten will
und wenn sie vielleicht sagen ja
natürlich ist das nicht so radikal
gemeint sie will nur sagen dass das was
aber leider sind sie gemacht haben doch
nicht so schlimm
nein es sechs außerhalb einer ehe im
zwölften jahrhundert das kann man also
die die ihre idee ist nicht banal freie
liebe wer soll das alles machen ihre ids
selbst eine ganz schlimme handlung kann
irgendwie gerechtfertigt werden durch
eine reine motivation und die motivation
in diesem fall war
liebe und es das ist die eine die
reinste motivation die es gibt wieder
uns hier in ihrem jetzigen kloster hat
sie das problem dass ihre motivation
schlecht ist also sie will nicht feucht
bleiben sie ist gegen ihre eigene welle
nonne und deswegen alles was sie tut
obwohl das was sie tut so sagen gut ist
oder angeblich gut dass wir alles
verdorben durch ihre schlechte
motivation also ich würde sagen dass
ihre idee durchaus philosophisch
interessant ist und auch zu der theorie
die wir bei agiles finden aber
interessant etwas anders und wenn dann
eigentlich radikaler und das finde ich
auch interessant also haben hier würde
ich fast sagen man wollte hallo es ein
gefallen tun und sagen
sie ist gut genug philosophen dass sie
eine idee von abi landes übernommen hat
aber ich würde sagen es ist gut genug
fälle so viel weil das sie habe leider
nichts übernommen hat sondern eine
eigene idee hat die eigentlich radikaler
ist wahrscheinlich weniger plausibel als
eine ethische theorie aber trotzdem
atemberaubend für ein philosoph der im
zwölften jahrhundert lebt und ich sag
gezielt philosophie ist mir egal ob ein
philosoph oder philosophen das sagt es
ist wirklich einfach eine sicht sehr
interessant als theorie dann übrigens
ich soll auch ich sollte vielleicht zu
geben dass das was ich ihr zu scheibe
ist ziemlich zusagen in den text ein
gelesen also was sie sagt ist hier ist
meine einstellung gegen der fähre
gegenüber meinen jetzigen legen geben
gegenüber
und ich versuche das zu sagen zu
rekonstruieren also was die theorie
dahinter steckt aber ich glaube das ist
das kann man aus dem text wirklich als
plausible auslegung holen
ok so viel zu hell riesen abels fragen
oder kommentare dass die würden übrigens
zusammenhalt begraben und es gibt eine
legende dass sie irgendwann aus gram
würden und ihre zwei skeletten haben
sich umarmt
aber ich glaube sie sind die der neue
der neue gratis im paradies zu besuchen
übrigens in diesem berühmten friedhof wo
auch jason ist und alle gehen halt und
die heißt ist ja genau und alle gehen
alle riesenarbeit vorbei damit zitieren
morrison besuchen kann
elend ich habe eine zeitlang in london
in der nähe von dem grad karl marx
gelebt denn dass sie beeindruckt
übrigens falls sie wissen wollen was was
sie mit mir machen sollen wenn ich tot
bin ist die sorge sagt wenn sie nicht
fahren können dann viel glück weil ich
bin nicht mein körper habe die
staatsreform ihr von mir die sie vor der
lmu bauen werden das genügt
ok so sind sie bereit für hd
er hat wirklich niemanden fragen über
karl marx
oder wie die stadt vielleicht auf einem
pferd gut okay so hildegard von bingen
sie ist vielleicht die berühmteste mit
natürlich philosophin das wahrscheinlich
das stärkste argument dagegen ist dass
sie keine philosophen war und das werden
wir besprechen müssen
aber berühmt ist sie auf jeden fall als
sie es in 1179 geboren und uns ja weil
dann wäre sie und hat schon als kind
mystische mystische erfahrungen und zum
beispiel sozusagen magische träume ist
zum beispiel sicher sie hatte einen
traum dass ein kalb geboren wird man sie
hat im voraus gesehen welche muster auf
dem kalt als app auf ihrem fell auf den
ball des halters auftauchen würde
und als das geschehen ist hat sie das
kalt dann als geschenk bekommen und wie
sie das bescheid ist dass sie schon als
kind ein sehr helles nicht ständig
gesehen hat und das war natürlich das
licht gottes
es gibt versuche das wissenschaftlich zu
erklären dass sie zum beispiel epilepsie
hatte oder sowas
also ich will mich nicht dazu äußern
aber es gibt solche erklärungen dafür
ich würde vielleicht eher sagen dass
erstens sind diese mystische erfahrungen
sind
wirklich anlass für alles was sie
geschrieben hat wie sie sehen werden
also ohne diese erfahrungen gibt es kein
helle gerade von wengen sie hatte nichts
geschrieben und wie sie aussehen werden
hat sie auf dieses nicht gerufen um
autorität für sich selbst zu gewinnen
also mehr oder weniger hört mich zu weil
ich das licht gottes in mehr habe von
daher könnte man sie vielleicht mit
jemandem wie jeanne d'arc vergleichen
und in den beiden fällen würde ich sagen
also einerseits wäre es verkehrt nicht
anzuerkennen dass beide wüssten wie sie
das ausnutzen konnten in ihrem kontext
also die haben das wirklich abgenutzt
und ausgenutzt sogar aber dass es für
mich keinen grund zu bezweifeln dass sie
wirklich irgendwelche erfahrungen hatte
also zu sagen dass das alles erfunden
würde es irgendwie für mich etwas
zynisch auf jeden fall an
sie kann von einer auf video oder von
einer wohlhabenden eigentlich nicht so
wohlhabend wie du oder aber von einer
reichen familie würde aber praktisch
abgelegt im kloster mit acht jahre alt
und als sie hat ziemlich viel über sich
selbst über ihr leben geschrieben und
wir wissen davon dass das für sie
wirklich schwierig war wie sie sich
vorstellen könnte es könnten sie würde
mit einer nonne namens utah british
abgelegt und diese jutta hat sie
ausgebildet sie zeigt was respekt für
diese frau aber sie hat sie eine nähere
beziehung zu anderen in ihrem umkreis
haben vor allem ein mönch namens
bollmann der die auch geholfen hat mit
ihren werken
er war praktisch nicht sein
ihr sekretär und hat dann den
lateinischen text ihre werke dann
verbessert übrigens jetzt in klammern
wir werden in den kommenden wochen sehen
dass mehrere frauen die mittelalter
philosophische texte geschrieben haben
und frank mystische texte haben in
volkssprache geschrieben und das ist bei
twitter und halloween und helga nicht
der fall
die haben alle auf der lateinisch in der
lateinischen sprache geschrieben und das
ist nicht zu unterschätzen denn latein
wollen natürlich nicht die muttersprache
von dieser frauen beziehungsweise war
nicht die muttersprache von
irgendjemanden latein war im mittelalter
sowie latein jetzt entweder lernt man
dass in der schule oder gar nichts also
latein auf latein scheiben setzt voraus
dass man über jahre ausgebildet wurde
das heißt dass man ist schon als
wahrscheinlich als kennt oder teenager
da muss man jahrelang latein studieren
um überhaupt lateinische texte zu
schreiben
hildegard selbst beklagt sich über ihre
mangelhafte ausbildung und die tatsache
dass sie sozusagen nicht perfekt latein
schreiben kann und deswegen war dieser
wollen meint da um zu helfen damit die
texte glatte vorkommen
aber man kann sie mit zeitgenössischen
gestalten vergleichen zum beispiel eines
sehr sehr ähnliches vergleich etwas
aufgemacht wird ist eine andere
zeitgenössische mystikerin namen
elisabeths von schöner
sie hat anscheinend keine dateien
gekonnt oder mindestens vier dateien
nicht gut genug selbst beteilige werke
zu verfassen
und deswegen hatte sie männliche
assistenten die ihre ideen oder texte
runter geschrieben haben auf dateien bei
hildegard ist vielmehr der fall dass sie
selbst eine schreiben kann
es muss nur korrigiert werden und das
ist nicht unwichtig weil am hildegards
also 1 1 ein reiz an hildegard und ihre
werke ist da ist er wie ihre stimme also
so wie sie schreibt und klingt das ist
sehr eigenartig und wenn sonst jemand
das schreiben müsste würden wir das
wirklich das würde uns fehlen würde ich
sagen okay
sie fing ihre werke diese lateinische
werke sie fing an diese werke zu
schreiben erst in 1140 irgendwas also
sie war bis dann es selbst so 40 jahre
alt oder ungefähr und das erste was wir
von ihr hören ist ein brief an den
berühmten bernhard von clairvaux und in
dieser zeit war beinahe heißt er
vielleicht bei naldos auf deutsch
kanadier der berner hat mit a
vielleicht sogar daran hat mit h und den
tee am ende
bernhard und er war unterwegs in
deutschland wenn man das dichter nennen
kann
in trier um leute zu überzeugen auf
kreuzfahrt zu gehen sie wissen
wahrscheinlich dass er in ein mächtiger
unterstützer war vom zweiten kreuzfahrt
und als er sagen
in der nähe war hat sie ihn
umgeschrieben und ihre mystische
erfahrung
beschrieben und hat praktisch gesagt sie
sind der große banalen von care wo sie
sollen mich beraten was ich machen soll
ich an unwissende frau ja aber typisch
hellgardt sie wüsste schon was sie
machen wollte sie hatte ihr buch schon
halb geschrieben und das buch hieß ski
was das ist eine abkürzung von stevie us
dominik kenne die wege des herrn und ski
was ist dann ihr hauptwerk wobei nichts
das einzige was sie geschrieben hat wie
ich kurz weg und kurzen sagen werde der
dieses werk würde sehr gut aufgenommen
beinahe hat auch hat sie auch
unterstützt und gesagt ja du musst
unbedingt allen sagen was was du
erfahren hast und das mit uns teilen
sozusagen
und sie hat dann in relativ kurzer zeit
einen ruf als große mystikerin dann
erreicht konnte ihre eigene ihren
eigenen kloster dann aufbauen das werk
von diese boden berg gezogen und war
praktisch die die hauptrolle in dieser
die in diesem kloster
also man man könnte sagen dass sie fast
wie ich hier auf dem handy geschrieben
habe
sie ist was als ob sie die rolle
übernimmt von dem alttestamentlichen
propheten
das ist sagt ich habe diese visionen
gehabt und ich werde ihnen jetzt ich
werde euch jetzt erzählen was ich
gesehen habe und um einen eindruck zu
geben wollte ich die erste version
teilweise vorlesen
also was sie gesehen hat und das ist die
erste sogenannte schau also das erste
was sie sieht wie es das erste was sie
berichtet wobei eine entschuldigung
wollte zwei passagen vorlesen wollte
zuerst ein ein autobiografisch eine
autobiografische passage vorlesen wo sie
beschreibt wie diese visionen gekommen
sind und dann wollt sich ein beispiel
geben die divisionen kennen also was was
man in den werken findet okay also
zuerst an eine passage aus ihre ddr
geschichte über das eigene leben im
jahre 1141 der menschen werde um jesu
christi des gottessohnes als ich 42
jahre und sieben monate alt war kam ein
feuriges lichts nicht mit blitzes
leuchten von offenen himmel hernieder es
durch stürmte mein gehirn und durch
blütenmeer herz und bloß gleich eine
flamme die jedoch nicht brannte sondern
lernte wie die sonne den gegenstand
erwärmt auf denen sie ihre strahlen nun
erschloss sich mir plus liegt der sinn
der schriften des alters des evangeliums
und der übrigen katholischen bücher der
alten und neuen testaments sehr
praktisch doch den worten ihre texte die
regeln der silben teilung und der
dramatischen fällen seiten erlernt sich
dadurch nichts
also hier was sie hier sagt ist ich
verstehe all die bücher die wir in
diesem kultur ernst nehmen meine
grammatik ist halt nicht so gut
wieso ist es dass ich das so gut da muss
man nicht vergessen grammatik und das
zur wm hin allgemein das war die
voraussetzung ernsthaft mit texten
umzugehen in der zeit also als ob jemand
sagt ich arbeite mit und juni habe ich
nichts gemeistert aber vorgeschrieben
hat mathematik da bin ich ein genie
aber für texte ich werde zurück dazu
kommen
ok jetzt die erste sogenannte schau ist
hier
ich schaute etwas wie einen großen eisen
vorwiegend berg das übrigens der anfang
von skechers ich schaute etwas wie einen
großen alten farben berg und darauf
schonte einer von solcher licht fühle
dass seine licht fülle meine augen
blendete von seinen beiden schultern
ging ein matter schatten ausgleich
flügeln von wunderbarer breite und länge
vor ihm zu füßen des berges stand ein
wesen das über und über mit augen
bedeckt war
so sehr dass man vor lauter augen nicht
einmal seine menschliche form erkennen
konnte vor diesem bild stand jemand
anderes im kindesalter mit matt farbenem
gewandt und weißen schuhen über er haut
ergoss sich von dem der auf dem berge
saß eine solche fülle von nicht dass ich
das des may kleine suns angesichts nicht
zuschauen vermachte von dem der auf dem
berge saß gingen viele lebendige funden
aus die gestalten mit sanften klängen
lieblich umflogen im berg selbst
befanden sich sehr viele kleine fenster
in denen menschen heute erschienen teils
bleich und teils weiß und dann kommt
eine stimme vom nichts auf dem berg und
sagt ihr was und das ist die vision
und es gibt eine reihe von solchen
visionen die dann ins gras dargestellt
werden
das ist wahrscheinlich nicht philosophie
was ist das schwer zu sagen vielleicht
ist das wirklich nur ein bericht von
irgendwas was sie wirklich gesehen hat
man könnte sagen das ist fast wie ein
traum
aber sie hat all das ist kein traum das
hat sie immer im wachen dann erlebt und
ich würde sagen dass diese visionen sind
sehr beeindruckend natürlich hab ich
sogar gedacht ihr könnt ihr versuchen
das als zu malen aber dann dachte ich
das einfach zu kompliziert wie man einen
wesen der liebe die wir mit augen
bedeckt war so dass man vor lauter augen
nicht seine menschliche form erkennen
konnte es wickelt klingt wie irgendwas
aus einem science fiction film und
zeitgenössische leser waren natürlich
sehr sehr beeindruckt und es gibt auch
dann anschriften wo leute hier versucht
haben das zu zeichnen
also das kam wirklich gut an könnte man
sagen aber was bei uns interessante ist
ist das sci fi es nicht nur aus diesen
visionen besteht sondern gibt es in
jedem kapitel eine vision und dann ihre
erklärung dafür dass sie geht durch das
die ganze beschreibung noch mal zitiert
ihre eigene beschreibung und erklärt
dann genau was alles bedeutet also man
könnte fast sagen das ist als ob jemand
einen text anbietet der offensichtlich
ein irgend eine allegorische bedeutung
hat weil niemand würde das lesen und und
nicht überlegen okay was ist das alles
was ist der berg was ist das licht wäre
es das mit den vielen augen wäre es das
kennt mit den weißen schulen als als
sehr rätselhaft ist wirklich ein
eigentlich gute haus durch ist ein
rätsel was man irgendwie entschließen
muss aber wir müssen sagen nicht als
leser alleine gelassen um dasselbe zu
machen
sie sagt uns genau was die bedeutung ist
sie bestimmt ihre eigene auslegung
könnte man sagen so in diesem fall
erklärt sie dass der große berge die
kraft und ständig kite des reiches
gottes ist das ist die welt des lichts
ist können sie wahrscheinlich selbst
wahrscheinlich raten was das liegt ist
gott die ist ja vielleicht nicht noch im
kopf dass das dieses dass von diesem
nicht zwei schultern daraus wachsen und
dann zwei flügel und die flügel sind
die sind sind gottes schutz und
gerechtigkeit es ist praktisch das
überschattet den berg und bewacht das
anscheinend dann gibt es diese wesen die
vor dem berg stellen das wesen mit den
augen ist die furcht des herrn was
beständigkeit fordert dass ken mit den
weißen schuhen ist so genannte armut im
geiste die nüchternheit liegt also
vielleicht wir würden das wahrscheinlich
minderwertigkeitsgefühl nennen aber für
sie es bescheidenheit
das ist die bescheidenheit und dann
kommen diese funken von berg nieder
und das sind die kräfte die gott erteilt
um ihnen damit wir ihn erreichen können
am ende sagte sie im berg soll befanden
sich sehr viele kleine fenster in denen
menschen heute erscheinen ab erschienen
teils bleich und als vice und gleich und
weiß können ist sehr ähnlich aber wie
auch immer das ist was ich über die
fenster sagt der hoch erhabenen
grund even alles durchdringenden
erkenntnis gottes kann desselben der
menschlichen handlungen nicht verhält
noch verborgen werden sie sagen dass
zeugen dass ihre laut oder reinheit in
sich selbst nicht mehr völlig klar was
das bedeuten soll
die grundidee ist die fenster sind
irgendwelche hoffnungen durch die wir
zugang auf gott haben sehr typisch
übrigens ist das demand die menschliche
figuren in der vision irgendwas mit
tieren zu tun haben
also das sind das ist das sind zwei
einstellungen die man gott gegenüber
haben kann also ja wort des herrn und
diese mindert das
minderwertigkeitsgefühl oder
bescheidenheit
das sind zeichen für uns wie wir dieses
lichts empfangen sollen und die fenster
sind praktisch vielleicht die hoffnung
für uns gott zu erlangen
ok also natürlich könnte man
detaillierte diese diesen ja diese
vision besprechen
aber was ich mehr betonen heute ist eben
dass sie nichts sie ist nichts sagen nur
passiv und man könnte sagen 'hey
rational bei sie ist nicht nur die
mystikerin die irgendwas sieht und
beschreibt und dann sagt ok macht ihr
was ihr wollt oder zum beispiel sie sagt
nichts
das gelehrten das für sie auslegen
sollen
das kennt könnte man durchaus vorstellen
zum beispiel sie könnte einen bernhard
von clairvaux schreiben ich habe das
gesehen was bedeutet das
das wäre sehr typisch gibt eine lange
tradition von träumen und wo es gibt
experten die erklären sollen
wie man diese mystische träume zu deuten
wie man die sie deuten soll das macht
sie nichts was sie sagt ist das war
meine erfahrung und das ist die
bedeutung meiner erfahrung
übrigens behauptet sie dass diese diese
erklärungen oder auslegung auslegungen
die sind genauso in diesem licht
begründet wie die vision selbst das ist
sehr wichtig also ihre jede berufung an
des lichts dieses licht was sie
unterstützt ist nicht nur ein licht und
nicht nur eine quelle für mystische
erfahrung das ist auch eine quelle für
auslegung der mystischen erfahrung
aber wenn wir jetzt zurück zu dir ist
wieder anderen passage die vorgelesen
habe wenn wir dazu zurückgehen
das lese ich noch mal vor teilweise sie
sagt okay die dieses licht kommt es war
nicht heißt es war nur warm und dann
sagt sie nun erschloss sich mir
plötzlich das sind der schriften des
salzes des evangeliums und der übrigen
katholischen bücherei der hut des alten
und neuen testaments also die und die
lesebücher also passiert ist sagt ist
mehr oder weniger das was ihr theologen
wie avatar dass zum beispiel was ihr
jetzt macht er versucht dauernd die
bibel und evangelium auszulegen und so
weiter das kann das kann ich auch wegen
dieses nichts was mir von gott geschenkt
würde und
ich finde das wirklich sehr interessant
ein handy gab weil das setzt vielleicht
in frage
unsere erwartungen mit der mystik oder
müsste überhaupt gegenüber
denn wir normalerweise denken
mystizismus ist irgendwas zu sagen über
dafür oder jenseits der vernunft eine
mystische erfahrung ist oft was dass wir
überhaupt nichts in wörtern erklären
können und ist auf jeden fall was das
nichts mit nationale erklärung zu tun
hat aber für hildegard gibt es nicht nur
keine spannung zwischen den zwei sondern
hat sie rationale erklärungen die
genauso begründet in der mystischen
erfahrungen sind wie diese visionen
man könnte sogar sagen es gibt zwei
komplementäre aspekten ihre mystischen
erfahrungen nämlich division selbst und
dann diese auslegung der version aber
auch die auslegung von büchern die von
anderen in genau der zeit anders
ausgelegt würden und man kann so weiter
gehen und sagen wenn zum beispiel eine
art oder aber lagers daher kommt und
sagt okay ich habe eine auslegung dieser
passage aus der bibel und dann kommt
hätte gesagt okay gut aber gott hat mir
schon erzählt was das heißt also das
hättet ihr eigentlich sparen können
dass das tut sie natürlich nichts weil
es so gewagt weil sie nicht aber was sie
was sie schon macht ist dann ihre
stellung als jemand mit einer einsicht
eine besondere einzig die andere nicht
haben
das betont sie und das nutzt sie auch um
autorität auch zb bischöfe gegenüber
so haben das werde ich ja bald sagen
aber sozusagen philosophisch gesehen
alles was ich jetzt sagen heute ist das
diadem ist das mystische erfahrung in
keiner weise mit vernunft oder
rationelle diskurs entgegengesetztes im
gegenteil das ist dass wir dadurch
ausgedrückt und die insofern divisionen
eine philosophische bedeutung haben
dann hat das was immer was mit ethik zu
tun zum beispiel diese zwei typen die
dann verkörpert werden also fürst gottes
ein wesen mit lauter augen also was
irgendwie alles sieht und das ist für
sie typisch können wir auch übrigens in
anderen werken von ihr finden
wir haben ein paar mehrere werke von
ihren nicht nur die vias sondern erstens
haben wir briefe an freunde anderen
nonnen und auch an die gelehrten
wir haben mit türkische texte wir haben
ein theaterstück und hier ist sehr
auffällig dass das thema der des
theaterstücks ist die tugend dass die
idee war anscheinend dass die nonnen in
ihrer gruppe in ihrem kloster
die sollten sich alle aus verschiedene
tugend verkleiden und dann sollten sie
erklären wie man gott
und es gibt einen text von einer hand
den weiblichen stückzahlen aus der zeit
um uns die sie greift hildegard an weil
das alles völlig unpassendes dass die
sich verkleiden und dann auftreten auf
der bühne ist sozusagen das was wir sie
wirklich schockierend was irgend was sie
über hello wie es gedacht hätte
aber das ist auf jeden fall interessant
natürlich liegt wie vorhergesagt habe
eine erinnerung an roswitha die auch
theaterstandort oder mehrere
theaterstücke geschrieben hat das
geschrieben und sie wissen
wahrscheinlich dass sie musik
geschrieben hat jede musikalische werke
sind sogar erhalten sie können cds
kaufen mit werken von hildegard wie nahe
sie wirklich an die echte musik kommen
ist vielleicht fraglich ich bin kein
musikhistoriker aber es so weit wie weiß
ist es ziemlich schwer
das durch dann genau wie mit alter musik
klingen soll nur auf hand der
manuskripten die wir haben aber es gibt
es musikalische werke von haben von
helligkeit ihr habt sogar ein werk von
hildegard genommen hast die musik für
meinen part cast für früher mit atelier
philosophie und das also wenn sie
möchten können möchten wie das denken
sie dass nur group google also hildegard
von bingen musik da kommen sie auf
irgendwas was angeblich so klingt wie
ihre musik
dann hat sie werke über naturphilosophie
geschrieben über pflanzen und vor allem
medizinische anwendungen von pflanzen wo
und edelsteine diese aspekte des bergs
beeinflussen sehr die jetzige ruf als
so zum beispiel irgendwann gesehen dass
ein ein bäckerei hat brot verkauft mit
hildegard von bingen rezept oder
irgendwas also sozusagen im außerhalb
der uni wird sie hauptsächlich als
komponistin und hallen medizinerin
gesehen und vielleicht auch als
musikerin
aber wie gesagt was oft vergessen
vergessen wird ist dass sie auch diese
sehr rationale rationelle seite hatte wo
sie erklärungen der bibel und ihre
eigenen versionen angeboten hat und zwar
auf basis dieses so genannten links
jährigen sich hätte es auch sagen sollen
dass ins gras ist es oft so dass sie die
wechsel zwischen auslegung jeder vision
und und auslegung der bibel
sie sagt dass irgendwer irgendwas in
meiner aus meiner version
und das ist genauso wie im bibel wo
estate bla bla bla bla und ich lege das
so aus und sie sehen dass sie
zusammengehören
also meine version bestätigt die bibel
oder umgekehrt
und man könnte sogar sagen dass sie sie
liest ihre eigene erfahrungen wie ein
religiöser text und geht hin und her
zwischen den der bibel und diesen text
was ihre mystische erfahrung war die die
werke die sie diese hatte die werke
übrigens enthalten auch ab und zu
deutsches deutsche wörter wo sie
vielleicht nicht die die lateinische
ausdrücke kante zum beispiel für
irgendwelche pflanzen oder mit der
mineralien oder vielleicht gab es
einfach keine lateinische ausdrücke
dafür also sind sie nicht manchmal
deutsch und lateinisch aber nur
vorwiegend in diesem natur für dessen
kontexten
die vielleicht vielleicht sind sie
skeptisch dass diese werke wirklich
naturphilosophie anbieten aber die sind
nicht nur zum beispiel rezepte oder
aufzählung von verschiedenen arten von
steinen oder pflanzen sie bescheid sogar
wie es kommt vorkommt dass mineralien in
in der erde verursacht werden und ihre
erklärung dafür ist hetze also ihre idee
ist dass zum beispiel sonnenlichts auf
einem berg scheint und die wärme wird
innerhalb der herde dann aufgefangen und
das verursacht edelsteine
es ist sie hat hauptsächlich interesse
an edelsteine
das ist zwar nichts richtig ich weiß
nicht ob irgendjemand hier neben taxi
geologie hat aber zb weiß werden hätte
steinen nicht durch sonnenlicht erzeugt
aber trotzdem dass das ähnelt
erklärungen die man auch in natura
philosophischen werken aus dem zwölften
jahrhundert finden kann also ich würde
das alles natürlich philosophie
beschreiben welche stellung hat der
erstens klassischen
das heißt die die philosophie die uns in
der ersten juni einfällt wenn wir über
philosophie in dieser zeit und natürlich
muss man nicht vergessen wirst du immer
noch hier im zwölften jahrhundert
das ist nicht die zeit von thomas von
aquin brennt oder sonst geht das so
weiter das ist die zeit für eine bilanz
von der schule von schardt also weiter
also wir sind immer noch in einer phase
wo alles dort ließ eigentlich
noch nicht gekommen ist und wo die
hauptquellen augustinus und poitiers
sind auch ein paar logische werke von
von alles offen ließ und natürlich kann
man nicht behaupten dass hildegard ein
teil dieser tradition ist sie kennt
mehrere texte die theologische relevant
sind zum beispiel augustinus aber es ist
nicht als ob sie kommentare mit ihr
steigt oder zu platon oder so weiß dass
sie sie schreibt keine werke die
ausdrücklich mit der fälle so wird der
hauptströmung der philosophie für die
situation im mittelalter
auseinandersetzen
allerdings gibt es einen fall wo es sie
sogar eine theologische theorie
kritisiert man hier so ist im voraus
gesagt werden dass sie genauso wie sie
manchmal sagt ich würde nichts aus
gewichts gut ausgebildet meine grammatik
ist schwach sagte mehrmals sie sagt auch
dass sie nicht in philosophie
ausgebildet würden
und hier kann man sie mit helau es
wirklich nichts vergleichen also helau
es war definitiv fertig ausgebildet
dankbar beladung und hildegard jedes mal
dass sie ihre beziehung so philosophie
oder des klassizismus vielleicht jedes
mal dass sie das beschreibt betont sie
dass das gar nichts mit ihr zu tun hat
also sie war entweder nach geteilt weil
sie keinen zugang
daran hatte oder ich glaube sie würde
sagen sie hatte glück
nun würde nicht dadurch verdorben das
ist vielmehr der einstellung weil sie
oft diesen theologen gegenüber sehr
kritisch ist sie
sie beklagt sich zum beispiel dass die
theologen jederzeit diese schafkopf die
natürlich noch nicht an der uni
der sieht tätig sind war die
universitäten kommen er ist eine
generation oder zwei später aber die in
dieser kathedrale schulen dann tätig
waren wie zum beispiel habitus die
verbreiten auf ketzerische ideen
sie sagt es in einer passage dass
gelehrten wie der mond sein sollen
der mit hilfe des sonnenlichts andere
körper also andere leute bedeuten und
stattdessen werden sie ketzer sie war
übrigens insgesamt sehr kritisch
ketzerei gegenüber und hat die dass das
ist die zeit der katarer in
südfrankreich und sie wusste davon hat
sich dazu geäußert und gesagt wie
schlimm die sind sie so was wie die sind
noch schlimmer als juden nicht sehr
schön aber sonst es sonst ist toll
auf jeden fall aber der der beste fall
wo sie sich zu sagen zu lassen
schaeffler sowie oder chirurgie äußert
ist in einem brief wo jemand sie fragt
was ihre meinung ist so eine theorie die
ein theologe namensgeber von cartier
vorgestellt hat und diese theorie war
das obwohl gott und körperlich und
einfach ist können wir zwischen gott und
seinen attributen unterscheiden also
gott ist ein ding und die gottheit ist
etwas anderes
und ist sie wird gefragt was sie davon
hält und sagt nein das ist falsch weil
das würde die einfachheit gott dann
zerstören wenn gott eine eigenschaft
hätte die ihm gehört vielmehr ist die
gottheit von gott identisch mit gott und
das ist genau meine das ist eigentlich
genau das ist was die sehr typisches
zeit für diese zeit und auch später im
mittel heute dass die stelle die sie
hier übernimmt ist eigentlich die
normale stellung in dieser debatte das
die eigenschaften gottes nichts geht
scheint oder unabhängig oder
unterschieden von oder unterschiedlich
von gott sind sondern identisch mit gott
sein müssen
sie ist zum beispiel mit thomas von
aquin einig wenn es um diese frage geht
leider sagt sie nicht viel mehr darüber
man kann davon mindestens einen eindruck
gewinnen dass sie mehr oder weniger
vertraut war
wenn es ein bisschen mit den debatten
die unter den klassikern dann schon
verbreitet waren
und auch ich finde es auch auffällig
dass ein männlicher kreis bonn ist
korrespondent daran dachte ihr diese
fragen standen also für ihn war es
irgendwie nichts nichts komisch oder
abwegig hält eine frau aus den fragen ob
wert vom portier ein sehr bedeutender
teil york derzeit ob er recht hatte mit
einer sehr technischen philosophischen
theorien
es ist interessant wie gesagt aber sind
jede eigene philosophie ideen und am
ende fast immer mit sex zu tun also
diese fragen wird der ausgelassenen
theologie oder sogar histologie ich mein
irgendwie könnte man vielleicht sagen es
gibt implizit eine psychologie hinter
ein werk des gegners weil weil sie eben
zum beispiel
hatte das ein nichts
diese feststellung begründen könnte aber
wenn sie explizit über philosophische
fragen spricht hat das was immer mit
tricks zu tun und was wirklich
interessant ist ist wie nah sie an der
hauptlinie der mit leidlichen kadic vor
allem des zwölften jahrhunderts steht
noch mal muss man nicht vergessen alles
total fertig ist jetzt unbekannt das
kommt er später im 13 jahrhundert also
für sie tätig das was sie aus akkus
tinas und poetisches und grobe gesagt
aus einer platonischen tradition
gewinnen können und sie steht wirklich
genau in dieser tradition
das wird ihnen vielleicht bekannt
vorkommen weil es erinnert an genau an
dem was ich aus der politik berichtet
habe wo gerechtigkeit ist wenn aldi
zentrale wichtig miteinander arbeiten
und vernunft muss die andere sind alle
kontrollieren und so das genauso wie die
typen konzipiert sie sagt immer wieder
dass rationalität die vernunft ist eine
kraft die die uns herrschen muss sie
unterscheidet sogar zwischen vernunft
und rationalität und seele
die ids vielleicht seele ist irgendwie
das liebt das lebensprinzip des körpers
und rationalität ist etwas das ihn über
schwebt und diese szene und körper
kontrollieren soll
und meistern soll laster ist dann immer
abweichung von der vernunft und ist
immer wenn man fünf und folgt
wie viele andere mitläufer philosophen
sieht sie den mensch als mittel wesen
zwischen den tieren und den engeln die
diese seele und körper mischung oder
komposition von daher in wir den tieren
die aus seele und körper bestehen aber
durch vernunft er wird den hängen und
was sich hier wirklich interessant finde
ist dass wir sind noch mal ein time und
meine rolle mich gegen diese idee dass
mystiker immer rational sein müssen
schließlich ist ein hauptbotschaft von
scivias und von ihren werken im
allgemeinen und auch von dem
theaterstück über die typen terminen
irgendwie meine hauptbotschaft ist dass
wir durch vernunft und rationell leben
sollen und wir sind göttlich oder auf
dem weg nach gott genau in sofern wir
das schaffen
also wenn wir wenn wir uns an die
vernunft anpassen und folgen dann leben
wir richtig und wenn nicht nichts und
das ist genau was wir aus den diesen
visionen lernen können und dann könnt
ihr vielleicht sagen dass die visionen
einen anderen weg bieten diese alte
philosophische überzeugungen zu
entdecken und ernst nehmen
ok letztes thema was sich bei hildegard
beschränken wollte minute noch das passt
ist was was sie über sich selbst und
über die tatsache sagen würde dass sie
dass sie weiblich ist
und hier kann man wirklich was hinter
der sache interessante passagen
und die zeigen also aus unserer sicht
würde man wahrscheinlich sagen sie diese
passagen zeigen wie ernst sie die
mittelalterliche einstellung erfragen
gegenüber selber übernommen hat also ihr
verständnis von frauen im vergleich zu
männern ist typisch für ihre zeit und
ist es nicht als ob sie sagt ihr habt
frauen übersetzt nicht übersetzt er hat
fragen unterschätzt weil schaut was ich
machen kann
das ist nicht der wirtschaft viel mehr
sagt sie immer wieder
ich bin nur eine frau und wenn ich was
besonderes erreicht habe hat es nichts
mit mir zu tun
das hat mit diesem nichts zu tun die zu
mir gekommen ist und sie spielt sogar
mit der mit der erwartung dass sie als
frau wirklich besser ist zu sein als
empfänger weil als frau ist sie passiv
männer also das typische antike und
mittelalterliche kontrast meiner sind
aktive frauen sind passiv also eine frau
ist sozusagen die der perfekte empfänger
für einen liegt was von außen kommt und
sie sagt immer wieder sagen wie das bin
nicht ich der das sagt dass es gott oder
das ist das licht gottes also man kann
das auf keinen fall zu sein
feministische sehen was sie was sie
halten meiner meinung nach was sie das
sagt allerdings ist vielleicht irgendwie
vielleicht interessanter was sie daraus
macht genau weil man in ihrer situation
kann sie natürlich nichts sagen
hier sollte mich zu hören weil ich
hildegard von bingen denn was sie
stattdessen machen muss ist sagen ist zu
behaupten alles was ich sage
das kommt von gott das genau was sie tut
ein sehr gutes beispiel da kommt aus
einer
debatte die sie hatte oder ein ein
streit eigentlich mit einem bischof der
durch ob von mainz glaub ich
und dieser bischof wollte eine nonne aus
dem kloster umsetzen und diese nonne war
hellgardt sehr lieb und sie wollte sie
behalten und es ist schreibt an diesem
bischof und sagt praktisch das licht
gottes hat mir gesagt ich darf meine
gehalten
kurzum das ist dass es eigentlich was
sie was sie in diesem betrieb sagt und
im allgemeinen hat sie immer wieder
versucht sogar kirchliche autoritäten
sie überwinden
dadurch dass sie ihre stelle ausgenutzt
hat als mystikerin und jemand der dieses
geschenk gottes hatte ein noch
schwieriger zeit übrigens was sie am
ende ihres lebens hatte war dass sie das
ging darum dass sie sie wollte jemanden
neben dem kloster begraben und der mann
würde erst kommuniziert und sie wollen
sie das trotzdem tun und dann als strafe
würde es eher verbotene musik in dem
kloster zu haben und das war natürlich
für sie das schlimmste was passieren
könnte und dann hat sie immer wieder hat
sich beklagt und hat es am ende dieses
steht auch gewonnen wobei klappt sie hat
die erste zeit über die neuen nicht
gewonnen aber jetzt versucht also die
also das ist interessant dass sie sie
versucht es
ich würde sagen sie gibt zu dass sie als
frau in einer sehr schlechten position
ist dass sie sehr schwach aufgestellt
ist aber findet einen anderen weg dann
macht auszuüben und andere tor gemacht
das ist interessant das werden wir auch
vielleicht ein bisschen beim echten hd
wird nächste woche sehen dass sie auch
mit dieser idee der passivität der frau
dann gibt es auch passagen wo sie über
geschlechts oder sexualität spricht zb
ist sie auch ein gros eine große
unterstützerin der keuschheit
genau wie burda und man hat von ihr den
eindruck nichts mit dauernd aber ab und
zu das sie sexualität sie nicht abwerten
will
andererseits hat sie sehr positive
äußerungen über den menschlichen körper
als ja von gott gebaut und perfekt und
so weiter die diese idee die wir vorher
gesehen haben dass der mensch zwischen
engeln engeln und tieren ist das
spiegelt sich auch in ihrer theorie des
menschlichen körpers und das ist
übrigens sehr typisch für das montierte
jahrhundert oder für mittelalte im
allgemeinen dass der menschliche körper
in sogenannte mikrokosmos ist was alle
aspekte des universums in sich hat und
das war nicht meine auch bei her
also man könnte sagen dass sie eher
negativ als sexualität ist aber eher
positiv körperlichkeit oder den körper
an sich was wir bei ihr nicht finden ist
diese erotische thematik die wir
vielleicht mit frauen mystiker im
mittelalter verbinden und was sehr sehr
starken mechthild und hartwig finden
also diese beschreibungen die sie über
gott hat diese visionen haben eigentlich
ein wenig mit sexualität zu tun also
gott ist nicht ihre liebhaber gott ist
die quelle eines lichts worin sie die
wahrheit sehen kann
oder würden sie diese bilder sehen kann
und dann auch die auslegung der bilder
und das ist wendig wichtig zu betonen
dass das passt so ein thema was ich
immer wieder in dieser vorlesung serie
dann erwähne nämlich dass man nichts all
diese frauen einfach pauschal nehmen
soll nun dieses besonderes irgendwie
verlockend zu tun wenn man zum beispiel
hält uns mechthild von magdeburg und
hartwig vergleicht alle weibliche
mystikerinnen innerhalb eines
jahrhunderts voneinander sehr ähnliche
denke würde man sagen ich würde genau
das gegenteil behaupten die sind alle
irgendwie mystikerinnen und die sind
alle natürlich weiblich habe das ist
ablenken finde ich mich zählt und
martina hdj hätten nur im 13 jahrhundert
existieren können
die haben in der in einer volkssprache
geschrieben und die reagieren auf
erotische themen aus der romantik
literatur derzeit das ist überhaupt
nicht was hildegard macht was hildegard
macht ist irgendwie mehr wie eine
mystische version von bruce poetische
oder also nicht poetisch aber so
bildhafte teile müttern auslegung dass
und philosophisch die sie thematisch
viel näher zu der philosophie des
zwölften jahrhunderts als die
philosophie von mechthild und heavy
metal und auch kann man sehen von dem
was ich heute gesagt habe dass alois und
handy gerade fast überhaupt nichts
miteinander zu tun
obwohl sie die hat zwei haupt weibliche
denkerinnen das wollten jahrhunderts
sind also noch mal es ist wie immer ist
wirklich eine feder zu sagen okay die
sind alle ähnlich nur weil sie frauen
sind
jetzt habe ich über die zeit gesprochen
tut mir leid es war interessant
[Musik]
und nächste woche